[Music]
we'll likely be breaking records this
week with the hot temperatures in las
vegas and it's really a lot for
anybody to handle but especially for
those who are new to the valley
oracle mana joining us now live outside
in that heat with
what some people are doing to try and
keep cool erko
well denise we all know the basics of
handling a heat wave
drink plenty of water wear light
clothing and make sure your ac
is working properly but people who've
just recently moved to las vegas
have not experienced the temperatures
that we're seeing this week
so we wanted to see how they're coping
coming to vegas
it was kind of a big shock david alcaraz
duran just moved to las vegas two months
ago
like many he sold his san francisco home
due to the hot housing market
but the weather he was used to 60 to 70
degrees on average
is definitely a far cry from the harsh
heat of the vegas valley
didn't realize that the summers were so
hot here the high temperatures this week
could break records one thing alcaraz
duran was surprised by
was how hot the inside of his car was
getting but he's already learning what
the locals do
one of my best friends actually
recommended that you get a sunshine
and put that up in the window so i never
had to have a sunshine sunshine before
but
i'm definitely going to run out to the
store and get one officials say even
those who've lived in vegas for years
still need a reminder
especially since this week's heat wave
is one for the books
for the first time my vehicle overheated
this year hasn't done it
in 10 years the best way to protect
yourself stay out of the sun
stay indoors between the hottest hours
of the day
which is about 2 p.m to 7 p.m that's
something alcaraz duran plans to do as
he settles in to his new home
we stay indoors try to stay in air
conditioning as much as possible
now for all our newer las vegas out
there we just wanted to give you some
extra tips
keep an eye on your car the heat can do
some serious damage
including sparking fires if the wires
melt so if you notice any issues get
your car checked out immediately
and do not park it in your garage also
the pavement
can get extremely hot so make sure to
walk your pets early in the morning
or late at night and you can also buy
them little slippers to make sure
that they're protected reporting live in
las vegas tonight orca mana 8 news now